back in the good old days if you are an
entrepreneur that managed to make it big
and built yourself a nice giant
successful business you were on top of
the world but you're ambitious you want
more more money more profits you want to
crush and suffocate your competitors
feeling problem is the thing that got
you here in the first place being
innovative and serving your customers
well will only get you so far moving
forward so what do you do you turn to
selling your products for a loss buying
up your competitors buying up other
businesses in your products supply chain
and other monopolistic practices but
unfortunately today with those pesky
antitrust laws that's just not an option
anymore it looks like you might just
have to keep innovating to stay alive
god I feel exhausted just thinking about
it but what if I told you there was
another way what if I told you that
instead of just working harder providing
a better service and innovating to grow
and stay afloat we could just have the
almighty government crush our
competitors for us now intuitively you
might be thinking that well gee Jake
that sounds all good and stuff but how
would anyone be okay with giving the
government that much power to make the
lives of big businesses easier that's a
fair point
but there's a very easy way around it
see instead of just outright proclaiming
to everyone our monopolistic intentions
we just you know slap some makeup on the
pig and say that's in the public's best
interests instead of telling Congress
that we want you to crush our
competitors for us we tell the world
that we need government to protect
consumers from greedy unsafe businesses
that the Internet is just too powerful
it's too important not to regulate I
think the real question as the Internet
becomes more important in people's lives
is what is the right regulation not
whether there should be while little
does the public know now where the
greedy businesses were saying to protect
them from that even though we can afford
all the lawyers and fees that these
regulations work hard to navigate our
pathetic competitors can't much for less
that little startup trying to get off
the ground or in other words we need to
learn how to play the game of crony
capitalism
[Music]
since you're gonna be learning how to
make boatloads of money as a crony
capitalist in this video you might as
well protect that money in your pocket
with a quality smart wallet like this
one from extra viewers of this channel
get a 15% discount with free shipping
and free returns with the coupon code
below by 1998 Microsoft was the biggest
company in the world by far one of the
most innovative companies in the world
controlling 90% of the world's personal
computer market and Microsoft and Bill
Gates for maybe a lot like you are right
now they thought that hey we're here
doing our thing business is going great
customers love our products so let's
just keep keeping to ourselves so they
spent zero dollars on lobbying or
cronyism and then one day in 1998 after
the politicians kept seeing just how
much money Microsoft were making that
they weren't getting their cut of knock
knock Bill Gates is called into the
Senate hot seat and at this hearing Bill
Gates was unfazed fearless even they
were literally brought in front of
Congress they were yelled at by a
Republican Orrin Hatch from Utah he said
you guys need to get involved here in
Washington DC you need to build a
building here you need to hire lawyers
here in other words the unspoken text
you need to bribe me and gates left that
hearing the same way he came in you
leave us alone and we'll leave you alone
fast-forward six months later Microsoft
got another knock on the door this time
from the Justice Department Microsoft
was found guilty for giving away a great
product for free this is Internet
Explorer at a time when we were buying
Netscape and paying money for it they
offered it for free and that was deemed
you know bad business practices there
was not any way they spent the next ten
years funding that case devoting a ton
of time money and resources to it
guess how much Microsoft spends today in
Washington DC
how much tens of millions of dollars
they have a beautiful building about
equal distance from the White House and
fun day for Congress they have lawyers
they have lobbyists Microsoft learned
it's lesson they got punished for
innovating so if you're making a ton of
money and you don't pander to the
politicians the voters will inevitably
come to your door so if it's inevitable
that we're gonna have to defend
ourselves against greedy politicians and
stead up just defending ourselves
why not profit from the to the other big
tech companies have learned from
Microsoft's mistakes and now take a more
offensive approach back in 2018 Amazon
was facing a lot of bad press for how
horrible life was for workers in their
warehouses and how some of their bottom
workers were having to live off of food
stamps because their wage was just too
low Jeff Bezos on Amazon Prime day
became worth 150 billion dollars when
he's worth that much money you begin to
start asking the question are companies
like this who are paying their employees
so little gaming the system joining me
now whether or not that was true doesn't
matter Jeff Bezos had two choices he
could either ignore the pressure and
just keep investing more money into
making Amazon better to keep his
customers happy with low prices or he
could raise the minimum wage to make the
critics happy he chose the latter option
and raised the minimum wage to $15 for
all Amazon workers saying that we
listened to our critics thought hard
about what we wanted to do and decided
we want to lead it sounds so noble so
self-sacrificing but you and I know
better because shortly after he also
announces that he'll be lobbying
Congress to increase the minimum wage to
$15 per hour which is a nicer way of
saying that Jeff is gently bribing
politicians to allow the government to
force his competitors expenses up
because after all Amazon is constantly
moving towards more and more automation
and as more and more low-skilled workers
are being replaced with robots a $15 per
hour minimum wage doesn't hurt Amazon's
bottom line so much but it does for
their competitors these O's knows a
higher minimum wage will hurt his
competitors more than it hurts him
clever use government to handcuff your
rivals and then pat yourself on the back
and pander to people who promise free
stuff around the same time Facebook's
Mark Zuckerberg found himself in a
similar position to where Bill Gates was
almost exactly 20 years later summoned
to Washington to testify in front of the
Senate
about the growing concern of Facebook's
power mark didn't make the same mistake
bill did he ditched his normal uniform
for a more respectable soup and tie as
soon as he was asked if he embraced
regulating the internet he responded
with an astounding yes crazy embrace
regulation I think the real question as
the Internet becomes more important in
people's lives is what is the right
regulation not whether there should be
as long Facebook is allowed to help
shape the regulations of course so would
you work with us in terms of what
regulations you think are necessary in
your industry absolutely
mark was thinking that screw the fact
that a free Internet is a major reason
why I was able to become the eighth
richest man in the world in the first
place they've already set their minds on
regulating the internet so if I just
cozy up with these vultures I'll get to
be on their side and not weigh down my
competitors for me if you were mark
you're already working on making your
product better every day there's only so
much you can do in that arena there's
only so many Engineers you can hire why
not work with the government to make
sure that that barrier for entry for
your competitors is as high as possible
while of course making sure that your
interests are protected or in other
words regardless if you think Facebook
is too powerful or the internet needs to
be regulated that is irrelevant what is
relevant is that he kissed the ring and
now will profit for it all without
having to do any of that pesky
innovation but crony capitalism doesn't
just work for a big tech it works for
pretty much any big business we're all
familiar with those poor old taxi
drivers that that just wanted to keep
providing a bad service to their
customers but these darn ubers and
lyft's are taking all their business
away because they're providing a better
service at a cheaper price and they're
nice to their customers we don't want to
do that now do we that's so much work so
what did we do we cozied up to our
politician friends and said la they just
don't comply with the law we have to pay
big money for licenses we have to get
fingerprinted we have to have commercial
insurance we're not trying to ban the
competition what we'd like is to be
competing with companies that follow the
rules and the taxi drivers got varying
degrees of success all over the country
the world with some places still banning
ride-sharing it's the same story with
other industries like traditional car
dealerships trying to ban Tesla stores
developers getting local politicians to
only approve their construction projects
thousand our cosmetology licenses for
thousands of dollars
public schools pressuring cities to
reject applications for more effective
charter schools building a profitable
monopoly these days may be illegal but
this might just be the next best thing
and here is how you can do the same I'm
gonna assume that by now you've already
built a giant successful business if you
haven't it's still good to know how this
works so that you have a roadmap as you
go because now is the point where you'll
start to feel like you're getting those
diminishing returns trying to make a
better product you've worked so hard
competing all these years it's time to
slow down or maybe if you're one of
those ambitious types that just wants to
keep growing to get a bear and bigger
edge on your competition like Mark and
Jeff then it's also time for crony
capitalism to be just another branch of
your business much like marketing or HR
if you're smart you would have been
building connections what politicians
this whole time as you grew but if you
haven't it's never too late to start
court them earn their friendship and
loyalty take them out to fancy dinners
stroke their ego make them feel special
make them feel that there's so much
why's are so much more noble and
selfless than the plebs they rule over
build up your presence at Washington DC
or at your local state government but
the most important thing to do is to max
out your campaign contributions this
will trigger the reciprocity bias the
cognitive bias that makes us feel
indebted to people who do us a favor
that in order to uphold the image we
have of ourselves as fair honest
individuals we have to return their
favor this is a state of mind you want
your politician buddies in as much as
possible then it's time to plead your
case to not just the politicians but to
the general public as well on why the
government needs to make life easier for
you the harder for your competitors this
is by far the trickiest part that
requires the most finessing and if you
seen any of my other videos you know
that PR is everything in today's modern
world if you have the public's
port you can have nearly anything you
want so how can you frame what you want
as a win for the consumer that if
government doesn't do this consumers
will be put in danger victimized even
raped by these greedy businesses our
competitors make tons of profits they're
just not raising their minimum wage
because they're greedy so we should have
the government force them to just like
we did voluntarily the Internet is too
powerful companies like us should be
regulated for the protection of
consumers remember regardless if these
claims are true or not it helps if we
actually make yourself believe that they
are this is the key into the hearts and
minds of the public because after all if
the general public doesn't think this
will benefit them why on earth would
they support it and even if you get
politicians to pass the regulations you
want without the public's support is
simply won't less just like the majority
of ride-sharing regulations didn't good
PR is the backbone of your success as a
crony capitalist if you get that right
and boom regulators will be convinced
not just by your generous campaign
contributions but also by the general
public that these regulations are
necessary that they're doing the noble
thing by passing them you're an
established player you have the
resources legal team and money to
navigate these regulations which
shouldn't be too hard in the first place
because if you played your cards right
you had a role in creating them but to
the demise of your competitors there are
time resources and most importantly
their profits will be squeezed just a
little bit more as you slowly wrap your
hands tighter and tighter around their
neck although would-be entrepreneurs
that maybe had an innovative idea for
this industry will see all the hurdles
they have to jump through best-case
scenario they'll be too discouraged to
even start worst case you'll slow them
down to give yourself a little bit more
time to get an even tighter grip on the
marketplace but perhaps my favorite part
of this whole scheme is that the general
public ends up helping the one thing
they claim to hate corrupt businesses
their natural instinct when they think
businesses are taking advantage of them
is that the government should do
something about it when really the more
regulations they fight for the bigger
the government gets the bigger potential
for favors we get in return
with traditional monopolies the general
public and the government despised us
but with this they both end up on our
side now you're probably thinking to
yourself but Jake where am I gonna store
all this newfound money I've made as a
crony capitalist that is such a great
question and you can solve that problem
with a quality smart wallet from Exeter
they're real leather RFID protected and
they come with an optional worldwide
solar-powered GPS tracking cards that
you can check your location of your
wallet wherever you are have your phone
notify you when you leave your wallet
behind if you can't find your phone you
can use the car to ring your phone and a
lot more features but perhaps my
favorite part Exeter is giving you guys
15% off with the coupon code below what
their standard free shipping and free
returns I'm running their slimmest model
called the Senate and I'm really liking
it so far but if you need more space
they also have their Parliament but I
personally like the Senate more because
it's less bulky so you cronies can claim
your 50% discount with the link below
and support the brands that help make
this channel possible because these
videos do take a lot of work to make
welcome to the watch data and club I
make video essays like this every single
week on the most provocative stuff in
the world of business so yeah if you
want more videos like this click the red
subscribe button below and turn on the
notification about to because it does
really help if you want to support this
channel financially pick up your very
own smart wallets below with follow me
on instagram at jake trend io that's
gonna be it for this video thank you so
much for watching
you wouldn't awesome I've been Jake I'll
see you guys in the next one
[Music]